welcome to this video playing gbg from
from the US so against the French as
their come on I'd like to play something
a bit different let's go for Kings
Indian attack see what is playing OKC
sim said he's playing the classical set
up with with them would be five very
often associated with the German Grand
Master working woman he's championed
that for for ages maybe I can take
trying to exploit the early b5 and now
maybe see for the non-diagonal is what
I'm trying to play play for ya Fisher
basics yeah the hope like play looks
like it's hanging by a thread but
everything's not protected he has not
cancelled but maybe a it does not matter
95 here I Scott righty five is good
night 194 is not so great takes Queen
takes Bishop c4 okay one or should I
play a slow moves like be three be three
is really slow I don't like that okay
let's do that this seems like the modern
amick choice 94 I just play quindi one
threatening Queen a4 ok this is more
logical anyway and down to the capture
guru ki one if you castles I techies
have nokia 28
so I'm trying to keep asking in the
center for the time being and I still
should have some pressure against the
center how to empower to assess
yeah Bishop t6 Islam this idea so how to
play Knight c3 on should I try to to
fight Bishop t6 even with Bishop f4
maybe okay let's do that fight the
immediate idea they at least yet some
coordination issues it's not a simple
technical task or something like that
maybe night here society i don't know i
will create a new pietas idea but i have
bishop age three right if he takes Queen
is seven
on 92 first 92 yeah this first I'm
threatening night c4 so rookie head is
not on and then maybe push up 83 yeah
yeah yeah this is better because the
night of the bishop he also needs to go
to an unstable square yeah yeah this
should be okay okay Queen takes Queen
e17 g8 what is my move check I don't
turn I don't have an immediate threat
can I can I do something with this
bishop this unprotected bishop combining
combining threats here or should I play
a rather positional move like Bishop g5
let's do that rope yet I can take of
course just just meeting as also why he
does not have an ID for something like
that also c5 was hanging this wasn't out
of the question as well
I don't really see a good move for him
twin d7 I take f6 it's not a queen trade
yeah something like that I was about to
suggest this but I can I can really just
take him and take him it's a tempo under
on the bishop yes and here rookie 7 all
night f3 looking for a film that's its
nest it's also looking good rook g5
check okay if I can they can take
but it don't secretly I don't see how I
win exactly okay let's involve the light
this also threat protects h2 that's
still opinion
Oh night h4 yeah okay this this should
win ready rook edge 4G success is
relatively easy lucky to have got Queen
f7 and Queen f7 are threatening anyway
Queen f7 teenage 896 check rook g6
hmm
Wow come on this is not not really
working on come on I don't believe it
she's really a defense no or crap aah
chak unbelievable really champion check
I cannot believe that that that there
wasn't the wind none why am I playing
that he just takes it in place a 2 i'm
such a time leading idiot oh come on aah
chak like this is this really hurts okay
complete ah what's wrong one what
position do I want to have to win him
unbelievable quite resigned I mean you
should try some other gay men
unbelievable whew looking at this with
the computer is really frustrating I
know Luke AE 1 plus 11 okay check this
is Plus 8 gookju success winning
immediately yeah well this is also
winning you can play whatever you want
everything winds beside what I play it
beside what I played unbelievable rupee
one is winning again so this one what is
winning now we'll give two wins
everything witness this is not winning
it Queenie 6 is also winning yeah
because I can take here yeah this is
also very good
with a good end game but I was so
frustrated that i'm not meeting that
they really played the rest even even
worse check and again i can get a play
here and have a better end game you had
a very good end game even he's got three
week pawns and um ah what a catch and
this is really hurting check check yeah
I now with 20 seconds I really I really
self-destructed this is already lost
yeah of course this this is very easy
even and it really took some effort to
lose this game I mean this was was
rather nicely played even check yeah
this is the easiest way to play rookie 1
i'm not understanding at the moment wire
to be honest take how do a winner I look
at these eggs at a queen d 6 okay I can
take here with a check ah yeah i yeah
this is this a sir this is
understandable yeah i'm just in terrible
shape at the moment oh wow okay well
thanks for watching